hello I'm Nick now and welcome to the
Emanuel Centre in London for this
intelligence squared debate eight years
ago Barack Obama took his place in
history as America's first black
president his slogan yes we can
elected with sky-high expectations he
would reclaim America's moral leadership
in the world he withdrew most US forces
from Iraq and Afghanistan his landmark
health care bill was passed but he is
presided over one of America's most
polarized eras that's evident from the
public reaction to candidates in the
current presidential campaign Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump lawmaking in
Washington today is gridlocked over
numerous issues so the motion for this
intelligence squared debate yes he can
no he couldn't Obama is a failed
president we have an excellent panel for
you arguing for the motion David from a
former speechwriter and special
assistant to President George W Bush
welcome and Christopher Caldwell
senior editor at The Weekly Standard a
conservative weekly welcome to you both
and speaking against emotion Neera
tanden she was senior advisor on the
president's health reform team and been
out on the levee French philosopher
author and filmmaker he recently made an
award-winning documentary peshmerga on
his five-month journey along the front
lines of so-called Islamic state or ISIL
ladies and gentlemen your panel
well shortly you will hear from the four
panelists - for the motion - against
I'll then throw the floor open to you
and the audience was asked to vote on
the motion before the debate and you'll
know which way you're thinking here in
the room let's now get the opening
statements from the panelists david
fromm not only did he work for george w
bush he was also senior advisor to Rudy
Giuliani's presidential campaigns his
latest book is 2012 y Romney lost David
from the floor is yours
thank you
24 hours before Russian forces invaded
Crimea the Obama administration briefed
journalists and Congress that the
invasion would not happen when the
Russians invaded eastern Ukraine anyway
only non-lethal assistance the kind not
very helpful in resisting an invasion of
your country only that was provided
tonight we are going to talk about the
kind of presidency Barack Obama has led
President Obama has certainly done major
and substantial things the question for
you is did you succeed in the tasks you
set yourself and President Obama really
began his office his term in office with
two great historic tasks before him one
was restored the American economy after
the financial crisis and recession of
2008 2009 my partner Chris Caldwell will
mostly deal with the domestic issue I
think it's safe to say though let me
just make this point that however you
measure it Americans today are not
better off I will talk about the other
tasks the president said himself his
task to improve America's standing in
the world and to bring peace and I think
if you survey the planet that what you
will see is that there is almost no
place on earth where the conditions
facing America the West the Democratic
world are not more challenging if not
more dangerous today than they were
eight years ago I began by referencing
Crimea and Ukraine today the first time
since 1945 a major power is waging a hot
war on the European continent 10,000
people are dead hundreds of thousands
have been displaced a civilian airliner
has been shot down there is no end in
sight and there is no serious process
even undertaken to begin to return peace
to the European continent across Europe
the borders that were lowered through
the true treaties like the Schengen
Agreement are rising again as all of
these countries cope with the giant flow
of migrants that began first with the
flow from Libya or President Obama
fought a war of choice and now from the
war that the president has repeatedly
spoken about in in Syria but has never
acted on
drue red lines where he would neither
make peace nor make war neither accept
Assad nor overthrow Assad but instead
stand by doing nothing making no choice
while the largest humanitarian crisis
since the war unfolded a humanitarian
crisis one of whose casualties has been
the integrity of the European Union and
very possibly the strength of the
transatlantic relationship we see across
the world American alliances weakening
one of the most important foreign policy
achievements of the Bush years was to
build a new strategic relationship with
India these two great english-speaking
democracies at last after many years of
estrangement finding common strategic
purpose in the face of aggression from
China China is more aggressive than ever
but the relationship with India has been
put on on ice but the thing I think that
maybe should most bother us is what is
happening with domestic terrorism the
recent we are recently in Orlando
horrible as it was was horrible horrible
thing was explained by this
administration not as it could be
explained as an act of gun violence it
was that and as an act of hatred and
fear against gay people it was that too
but when this administration releases
the transcripts of what that caller said
they deleted any reference to Islamic
ideology you can't find and stop what
you won't see and act against there has
been more internal Islamic terrorist
violence in the United States since 2008
than ever before and yet the
administration won't say anything about
it and is therefore defeated in doing
anything about it and that is a failure
that is dividing our country it is
dividing your friend and that is setting
in motion a tone style of radicalism and
civic unrest that is dangerous to
democratic institutions I'm not a trump
supporter by any means I'm horrified by
him and yet when I see where did what
made this sinister and buffoonish event
possible I think it is the insecurities
set in motion by this president's
refusal to act against the greatest
internal threat to the safety of the
United States the greatest internal
threat to the safety of Europe was
and I thank you for your attention
David Frum speaking first for the motion
now the first voice against the motion
Neera tanden one of the architects for
Obamacare recently listed as one of the
most powerful women in politics by both
Fortune and Elle magazines today she's
president and chief executive of the
think-tank
Center for American Progress Neera
tanden the floor is yours
let me start off with just a response to
a few of David's comments and then I
will speak mostly about domestic policy
but I will start start where he ended
which is the nature of politics today in
the United States and I have to say that
to blame Barack Obama for Donald Trump
is just a little too much for me to take
Donald Trump is evidence of the failure
of the Republican Party and the failure
of Republicans who from the beginning of
this administration chose to obstruct
the president in everything he tried to
do and the idea and the idea that he is
a product of insecurities and
insecurities about America's national
security is is frankly outrageous to me
now the president has not solved every
problem at America I would agree we do
have some problems that remain but on
the challenges he set out eight years
ago he has made incredible progress
let's take the economy the economy is
one of the United States which is
stronger than it has been in the past
not just from 2009 but even before today
the United States remains a beacon of
innovation openness opportunity and
prosperity for the world and it's not
you know in spite of President Obama's
leadership
it is in part measured by it we have
taken real steps on the economy our
deficit is down 70% our unemployment
rate is four point seven percent now the
president also passed the Affordable
Care Act 20 million people have coverage
it's a little odd to talk about these
issues in another country which has
universal coverage but passing even the
Affordable Care Act was a gargantuan
effort that is succeeding despite every
attempt to stop it it is succeeding and
perhaps most important for the
president's legacy for future
generations the United States is now
leading in climate we've heard for years
that China won't act India won't act all
of these countries have acted because
the United States
leading and the Paris Accords were made
possible by all of our leadership
finally just on the domestic front I
would like to also talk about this the
real gains we've had on social justice
issues in the United States not in spite
of the President as we have at past
presidents but because of the
president's leadership women can now
serve in the military LGBT folks can
actually get married these are trends
that are that are producing more and
more and greater equality for more
Americans these are important
significant issues that the president's
helped lead on now David talked about a
number of issues around the world and I
would say he is right David knows all
too well what the United States did in
Iraq and I have to say I find it
difficult to hear criticisms about the
president's response to Isis from people
who supported in a war a war of choice
that helped create Isis in the first
place
there are real angers in the country and
some of those angers anger and
resentment is fueled because we had a
President Obama but he should not be
blamed for that anger it is not his
fault people are angry because of the
kind of president he is we will see in
November whether the country is going to
feed on that anger or respond to it with
a different kind of politics and I
myself am optimistic because I believe
the president has done great things for
the country and great things for the
world thank you
Neera tanden
the first voice against the motion now
the second voice for the motion we have
Christopher Caldwell senior editor at
the Weekly Standard in the u.s. prolific
essayist and author his latest book is
reflections on the revolutions in Europe
Chris Caldwell Florida was
good evening thank you for having me I
have to say probably like David - I
would love to be arguing this this
motion from the other side box I I tend
to feel as as most Americans who were
enthusiastic about Obama in 2004 do
today a little bit disappointed and
taken for a ride I think that Obama has
wound up being the greatest recruiter
that the Republican Party ever had
Republicans now hold their largest
congressional majorities since the since
the 1920s when Obama came to power
Democrats controlled most of the
country's state governments of which
there are 50 they now control 19 since
since Neera brought up the Affordable
Care Act Americans just don't like it
for the most part now I also think that
Obama does deserve much of the blame not
all of it but but much of it for the
political crisis that we're that we're
going through now Republicans have
nominated a man named Donald Trump who
isn't even sure that Barack Obama was
born in the United States and many of
his followers love him for this but the
distrust is actually not confined to the
to the Republican Party I think Hillary
Clinton who is Barack Obama's endorsed
successor and was his Secretary of State
has taken all spring to defeat a man who
heretofore it but on the fringes of
their party and who accuses the Obama
era Democratic Party of being a tool of
the plutocracy the country the whole
country now is is feeding on anger and
if you if you don't blame Obama for it
it's it's it's worth worth asking why
there is the crisis now and why not
eight years ago when our country seemed
to be in a more precarious position I
would say that it's because of those
promises that he has broken
and he's broken them by making the
country less democratic and that's what
we need to hold him accountable for
tonight whether you like his policies or
not the motion tonight has nothing to do
with whether Barack Obama was a better
president than george w bush and it's
probably a good thing for David and me
that it doesn't so I would even defend
most of Barack Obama's foreign policy I
think he's made mistakes I think
probably the Iran deal was a mistake I
think certainly the invasion of Libya
was a mistake but I think that Obama's
decision not to bomb Syria in August of
2013 was actually prudent given us power
there are tremendous pressures on any
president to fight optional Wars and I'm
glad he resisted the pressure to fight
more of them the problem is that in
focusing when he focused on domestic
issues his successes all came at a steep
price in damaged institutions you know
democracy moves slowly because listening
to the public and listening to the
people takes time Obama sees this
slowness as a problem of democracy that
he needs to correct and that's what's
made American democracy so unstable in
the last eight years when President
Obama wants something America can't wait
and it's always an emergency the
president prefers to work by executive
order and and there are some celebrated
examples of this that have driven the
the the country up the wall he's moved
to give working papers and tax numbers
to illegal immigrants we used to live in
a country where citizens chose the
president and now we live in a country
where the president chooses the citizens
but if it don't doesn't bother you that
um that is anti-democratic I hope it
bothers you a bit that it's plutocratic
so I'm afraid to call Obama a successful
president is to accept the ruling
classes own verdict about how excellent
and virtuous the ruling class itself is
and that's why I urge you not to do that
I urge and ask you to vote for the
motion thank you
Christopher Caldwell thank you very much
indeed now the second voice against the
motion been up on the levy philosopher
writer documentary filmmaker especially
outspoken in the wake of the Paris
attacks his books include left in dark
times a stand against the new barbarism
been out on the levee the floor is yours
against the motion
I would like to just to express what
appears to me to be facts reasonable and
objective facts there is a first rule
which is to see from where of this
presidency started in the case of Barack
Obama it started during the biggest
economical and financial crises with
America and the world so since the
thirties Barack Obama was in charge he
acted it appears to me as a foreigner
with cold blood with wisdom in unknown
territory taking some decisions which
were very odd in the American culture
like the nationalization of General
Motors at the end of the day he handled
this crisis as probably not a lot of
presidents would have done at his place
if you try to make the balance sheet of
presidency you have to to remember what
were the promises these promises were
not of course all of them fulfilled he
did not close Guantanamo for example and
there is other things which he did not
do but objectively if you try to be just
decent and homeless you have to admit
that there is a lot of these promises
which were fulfilled and accomplished
the gay wedding the gay marriage it was
not so easy especially after this huge
and tremendous crisis to go in the deep
end of the extreme poverty and through
the health acts of his presidency the
Obamacare
to repair some of the biggest damages of
this mad economy which is the economy of
all of us today not so easy when you
inherit of the governance of a country
where you have millions of songs and
daughters of illegal migrants who go to
university who want to enlist in the
army to deal with this situation he
promised he would deal and he dealt in a
way the DREAM Act was repeated but some
of these situations were settled if you
look at the balance sheet you have to
see also what way not only his promises
but our expectation it was clear that
the election of Barack Obama would mean
and could mean and had to mean something
in this dark part of American history
which is marked by the racial race
question he did it he did it in a very
wise way when you speak about the
balance sheet of Obama you have to have
a world also for the style of the
presidency of Barack Obama there is such
a decency such honesty such a great and
cool style in this embodiment of the
American history and Rieman by Barack
Obama and this again in the uncertainty
of politics and history has to be put at
the credit of Obama the recent speech of
Barack Obama in April in London about
the brexit is the denial to those who
believe that he definitely shifts from
Europe to Aria Europe is still
considered at the end of this presidency
as one of the roots of America these are
the reasons
why I should I will certainly not vote
for the motion and I asked you not to
vote too much for it also thank you
right let me ask for the microphones to
be prepared we got four of them let's
have them coming down please because I
want to move on very quickly but before
I do 18% of you had not made up your
minds when you came into this room but
for the motion 17% agree with emotion
but 65% are against the motion so David
and Christopher you have a bit of work
to do in the coming minutes let me now
get the microphones number three please
are you for or against the motion I
don't know yet but thank you very much
for our wonderful debate is the question
well is the problem really that we the
people place too much expectations in
politicians do we really believe that
politicians can heal the sick cure the
blind turn water into wine and part the
Red Sea
thank you stack that went up and can
everyone stand up when you make a point
please microphone two over there for or
against the motion against the motion
Bennett or Olivia mentioned the balance
sheet for Obama and we can sort of trade
well he achieved this promise or he
didn't achieve that promise for the rest
of the evening
but I don't feel that any of you
actually define what you mean by success
or failure in a presidency and if you
could say how you define that and
perhaps named a successful president
come to that in a moment only number one
please for or against the motion for the
motion as one of the people in that
generation that was inspired by Obama
I remember rushing home from school on a
January morning in 2009 to watch that
first inaugural and I think the really
important question here is that if it
weren't for the the beautiful oratory of
Obama the speeches after national
tragedies that can move us all to tears
than the skills a politician of Obama
would we even be sitting here all right
go ahead please for against the motion I
am for the motion and I'm very
disappointed that David and Christopher
did not give it that our argument I
think that there's a whole lot more that
could have been said what should they
have said well Bernard mentioned it
about Guantanamo I find him a very weak
president
I feel that we've been in many
situations where he could have taken
strong action
he makes America look weak which as an
American I find heartbreaking
thank you David
angry sway you've pulled your punches I
think your reference to the president's
strength or lack of it actually points
to something that is one of the greatest
dangers of this evening and as you and
that is near tandon's reference to the
obstruction the president faced and this
goes to a point the Christmas one of the
features of the Obama years has been to
suggest that when Congress or the
Supreme Court does their duty they do
something wrong so when Congress
declines to do what the president asks
that's not obstruction that's lawmaking
and when the president asked for law and
doesn't get it that is not a failure of
Congress that is a decision by Congress
when the president proceeds anyway that
is an act of high-handedness respond
just to that just to clarify what an
obstruction is when 150 House
Republicans support an infrastructure
bill the same infrastructure bill the
president supports they supported in
2008 150 they vote against it when he
becomes president the same exact bill
that is what I am labeling obstruction
of course House Republicans cannot
support the president's position of
course they can but when you have the
same policy that they championed before
he became president opposed it after I
became president there's something going
on there and it's not just an
ideological difference because they
supported the same bill before Chris
Caldwell v the suggestion you're really
pulling your punches well no III
actually disagree with the idea that
President Obama is a weak president
could I address what the man up there
said about Obama's stirring oratory
after national tragedies and certain
things that gets us close to what we're
trying to discuss tonight because the
problem we have in the United States is
half the country finds that stirring and
half just is deaf too it doesn't hear it
it has turned it off the country is
totally split into well fine but perhaps
the real problem is an emerging changing
new system of class and and that that
has got run rampant under Obama's watch
and no one has paid attention to it
you're again just told you what is
obstruction I would add to what she said
filibustering is obstruction bailout is
obstruction leading the country to the
edge of bankruptcy for ideological
reasons all that was obstruction and
these were the ordinary life of this
American administration what is the
successful presidency some of the most
ambitious bills which he passed were
passed without his majority at the
Senate and the Congress in the last
month compromising with the opposition
compromising with the Republicans this
art of compromise it again the sign of a
sane good and maybe grand policy David
Frum we will not be able to arrive as a
definition of a successful failed
presidency if we persist in deducting
the giving Obama President Obama credit
for things he did not do and denying him
blame for things he did do earlier in
this evening you heard that it was
President Obama who took the decisive
actions that prevented the financial
crisis from turning into a global
depression that's simply not true
the Troubled Asset Relief Program all of
the measures that saved the financial
community happened before January of
2009 they are passed by President Bush
to the often to the despair I think that
it was his finest hour but to the
despair of many and his party had
destroyed a lot of his credit within the
party but whether you approve of those
actions or not they were not Obama's
actions Obama's actions happened after
he was inaugurated not before what he
did not do save the world from a
depression what he did what he did do is
look the other way while Isis gathered
stress okay I just need to be clear on
it and
the question about Isis just to not
rewrite history here is if Saddam
Hussein was in power would Isis have
developed this is a question obviously
there's a number of things happening in
the Middle East but I think if you want
to criticize the president's actions in
the Middle East you have to be honest
about the mess he picked up because of
the president because of President
Bush's decision to in fact invade a
country that did not pose a direct
threat to America's national security
interests
President Bush is not an adult tonight
you can think better of him or you can
think worse of him the question is is
this current president given let's say
he was handed the worst hand in the
world did he play it well is the world
more peaceful it is not is America more
secure it is not is Europe stronger it
is not is America richer it is not are
people living longer they are not the
country David he is responsible for his
own record right what I'm sorry
the good thing Barack Obama did is to
try to appease auto intervene in the
clash between the two islam's this is
one of the good achievements of Barack
Obama to acknowledge the fact that there
is between the moderate Islam and the
radical Islam between the Democrats in
Islam and the fascists in Islam in a
real war and he took part from day one
of his presidency for the Democrats
against the Islamists and the radicals
and this is a good thing also
right I want to get plenty of questions
please one thing we haven't talked about
is Cuba I just wondered what both sides
view was on fixing the relationship with
Cuba right microphone to back to
domestic policy do you feel that Obama
has been a failure in amending America's
gun control policies microphone 3 stand
up and are you four against the motion
against could you comment on the
argument that because Obama is so strong
rhetorically he's so good at
I think getting people on side when he
speaks that there's an argument that
when he comes to put his speeches into
actions and tries to pragmatically carry
policies out he makes people feel that
there's a gap between his rhetoric and
his actions and almost the way he's so
good in front of people and it speaking
has actually worked against him and made
a lot of America feel like he's failed
David Frum particularly this question
about Cuba it was a side issue it was a
piece of overdue business it is you yeah
it was this post Soviet Union post
Soviet Union there was a leftover piece
of Cold War business it was good to tidy
it up
not an important achievement it was
bombing gave the Cubans what they wanted
they accepted deal done turns its back
on a fifty-year of failed policy it's a
good issue and an important issue no
guns and rhetoric this is really
important and this goes to I think one
of the fundamental aspects of failure I
have a different view on guns for most
Republicans I I think they are way too
common there I think something like what
almost a hundred million more of them
today than they were on the day Barack
Obama took office we should have fewer
and especially of handguns a lot but
here's something we know about the way
the gun debate takes place this is where
that speech on rhetoric this question of
rhetoric is important the United States
will make progress on the gun issue when
individual families decide it is
dangerous more dangerous to have a gun
in the house than not and that is simply
good science that is just the fact it is
more than ever gonna make it but when
President Obama uses his rhetoric you
find it as the other questioner said you
find it uplifting the majority of the
country does not and we get more guns
and more suicides and more unnecessary
homicides and and what looks to those
who are simply disposed to be
sympathetic to the President as a
success is in fact a gigantic failure
leading to stasis from thank you I just
want to respond and dense because David
has made this point in and it really
underlines a lot of the discussion we're
having tonight which is essentially
blaming Barack Obama for the hyper
partisan response that he gets from the
other side okay I just need to say I
reject that completely if the idea is
that the nation has a tragedy like Sandy
Hook and the president can't respond
because Republicans are going to be
hyper partisan in their response to his
what he's saying that is not a failure
of both sides that is a failure of one
side to put the country's interests
above political response and I am
I am glad president chose not to do that
mr. Caldwell blaming Obama for the hyper
response from the other side I think
you're right that there is a real
critique of Obama to be made from the
left because Obama represents something
that a lot of people don't yet
understand which is that the basis of
class have shifted class power comes now
not out of industry and real estate and
raw material but out of knowledge and
universities and Silicon Valley and
these are places where Obama that Obama
commands an almost unanimous majority
and Obama seems to not to realize that
he's speaking from the upper end of a of
a class divided and and and and that's
the source of a lot of the
misunderstandings that have gone on
tonight
then are only the people are deaf to
these brilliant speeches I don't
understand well so we would have to
reproach Barack Obama to speak as a
creme de la creme we would have to
regret that he speaks as an intellectual
that he tries to to get find solutions
and based on reflection and not on
populist resentments I think that this
has to be put also to the credit he was
not elected by the Silicon Valley as far
as I know he was twice elected by the
people of America by the minority by the
Latinos which Donald Trump who they
insult by the African Americans who feel
who felt him as one of their sons and
brothers so a man coming from there and
expressing himself as a decent
intellectual I think that this is the
best of America of always and of today
thank you right down here and there's a
lady over there I think
please microphone to a couple of
questions I think are you for organs am
against and when Obama became president
before even he took his presidency the
leader of the Senate said that his goal
was to make Obama a one-term president
this was before I even start ruling more
than 80% of American members of the NRA
actually are Pro some kind of a check
but for the NRA has refused to actually
go with that in the Senate has it
decided not to talk of that as well
thank you over there the lady please I'm
for the I'm for not against I'm just
wondering very briefly if mr. Obama is
Donald Trump's best campaign manager is
there a lady over there who wants to
come in please or is your hand going up
for other reasons there I been lucky
enough to be employed and have health
insurance throughout my life but I have
friends and colleagues who lost their
jobs
and lost their health insurance and when
I was back home visiting when all this
was being debated I was shocked at the
advertisements that talked about death
squads the first president brave enough
to risk his personal career on something
he believed was right and I'm a
Republican and so when you say that
Americans were against it I wonder how
much of that was because of the
advertisements they were watching on
television constantly may I take the
question yeah I'm not sure I I agree
with you that I think that the the the
insurance companies can be counted among
the authors of the of the Obamacare I
also don't believe that Obama took a
great risk to his political career this
has been the crown jewel of democratic
policymaking for about two or three
decades and in fact Obama pursued it too
the absence of of other initiatives
related to the to the finance crisis it
totally occupied his presidency for the
first 18 months at a time when the world
was in in economic crisis this is a
great opportunity for me to just say a
few words about the Affordable Care Act
and the truth is that let's put the
politics aside there are people alive
today because of the Affordable Care Act
people who would be dead if they did not
have that insurance so regardless of how
popular it is it was the right thing to
do on the issue of Donald Trump and
Barack Obama I will just say again that
Donald Trump won the Republican primary
people did not have to vote for him they
chose to and I don't think you can hold
Barack Obama responsible for the
decisions the Republican Party makes I
hope we don't do that now or ever in the
future as near says Republican Party has
brought Donald Trump on itself the pret
the president's popularity has risen in
reaction to that as Donald Trump has
appeared on the scene Hillary Clinton of
course remains also a desperately
unpopular person and we are in a state
of political crisis at the end of the
Obama presidency from thank you joe de
caminha - oh should I get small what I
would like to say of course Obama made
mistakes Syria of course he was
unsuccessful
gun control to reply to the question
which was put here unsuccessful you just
had to see his own face after the
Orlando killing to know that he himself
is aware of the unsuccessful of his act
but he has to be credited on my point of
view number one to have stood to have
standard by his words number two to have
taken the risk so often to be unpopular
we took a lot of examples in the
beginning of this discussion and at the
end to see an American Statesman making
politics in a complete opposite way of
Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump this is
not a bad news and I hope there will be
some others in everything of this
Obama's legacy
right at the fact on microphone for if I
could possibly rephrase the question on
what a successful president is in my
view at someone who makes others lives
better I think we're all better for
Obama having been elected but I think
that's about it
and I think his most successful action
has been to increase the rolls of public
unions in the US which is really quite a
European skill microphone fool please
I thank Miss tenon for her arguments and
I'm disappointed tremendously mister
fromm how about some responsibility for
us the reason less and less people that
are like this present are running for
office is because of this tremendous
scrutiny and this tremendous expectation
the expectations should be on us for all
of us to take some responsibility for
our place in this world people didn't
listen to Barack Obama on guns they
didn't listen to Bobby Kennedy who died
and spoke about it and asked people not
to to engage in that kind of violence
okay it starts with us who's got the
microphone there please focusing on the
motion again obama is a failed president
and you know how do we define success
and it isn't about some of the things
that people are spoken about today it's
not about popularity and it's not about
good intentions and it's not about
rhetoric not about integrity it's
actually about leadership isn't it both
domestically and abroad and and I would
suggest that that would be a problem
when we evaluate Obama's contribution
thank you right let's pick up on
particularly one of the trends which has
come through which is what makes a
successful president there was a remark
right at the top near about about the
best thing that happened to him was
simply being elected after that it's
been not successful you know I think we
actually should look at how the country
is doing and related to the policies
he's put forward from a social justice
perspective from a perspective of how
inclusive America is America is more
inclusive today
than ever in its history women's rights
have been advanced in the military and a
range of other issues LGBT rights in
terms of the economy I particularly like
to make this point internationally which
is absolutely the United States has
challenges absolutely we have challenges
in the economy the goal we have going
forward is to ensure that those profits
are better shared in the economy not
worse shared that means building on his
policies not going in the opposite
direction from you know I'm afraid that
along with the big plane of the mansion
scrutiny is part of the job and I'm
sorry and I don't think the President to
give about President Obama credit this I
don't think he would say what you have
said that it is our job not to
disappoint him I think he does
understand that he works for the
American people but as and not vice
versa but as for the suggestion that
it's some kind of conspiracy theory to
note that you know wet in the face of a
wave of Islamist violence inside the
United States the president has looked
away but you can't defend against what
you won't acknowledge the phrase
Islamist terrorism is not some talisman
that we demand the president say to make
us feel good what we want to know is
does he understand the problem and can
he connect the national security dots I
don't blame the president for any of
this but it is it is because I think
what he's trying he's trying to do
something else that he thinks is more
important but naming your problems in
order to solve them is important too
there's no power in it when you say the
word we do not end terrorism it's not
it's not the difference between success
or failure using those words as the
president used them just last week so
that issue I think as a side issue to
the debate of whether we're secure or
not
well thank you to all four of our
speakers I now have the result of the
vote by you here in the Emanuel Center
here in London let me remind you the way
you're thinking when you came in here at
the start of the debate for the motion
seventeen percent against the motion
sixty five percent undecided eighteen
percent a reminder that the motion is
yes we can
no he couldn't a bar map is a failed
president well the result of the debate
is that there's been a significant move
towards the motion particularly by the
undecided only six percent of you
haven't made up your minds thirty five
percent are now for the motion and
there's been a reduction in the support
against the motion to fifty nine percent
there's so there has been a eighteen
percent swing towards the motion but not
enough to carry it so I declare the
motion defeated but by a narrow margin
that when you first came here thank you
very much indeed to all of you
thank the speakers to you the audience
here in the Emanuel Center a fascinating
debate
my thanks to intelligence squared for
making it possible goodbye for me Nik
gowing and everyone here in London